[Musik]
etwas knapper zu kommen beim neuen video
games hat ein bisschen später ist so
krass irgendwie kommt mir so vor als
wäre es gestern noch um eine dunkel
gewesen ist am 18
das ist immer noch hell wir haben jetzt
eine neue gasse neckel super schön
gemacht es ist gar zum ersten mal
ich bin ja nicht so oft verletzte was
wenn ich an diesen schon gelesen und
zwar war ich gestern spontan ganz von
fahrten mal wieder bei burger kings und
bin reingegangen und habe so ganz hat
gesehen wie gaswolken macht jetzt
einfach hot dogs das habe ich jetzt
gestern nicht probiert aber ich habe mir
heute morgen gedacht
das musste einfach probieren macht dazu
doch einfach mal ein video eltern
wichtig sind ja bekannt zu burger und
nicht gehört hat also schon sagen ich
habe auf jeden fall noch zeit aussieht
voll schöner dinge himmel der himmel
klart auf jeden fall megageil ich würde
sagen die fans einfach mal los ich gucke
mir das ein bisschen genauer an was da
genau gibt dann probiere ich das mal und
sagt selbst ich bin ja so begeistert vom
himmel guckt euch erfahren
nur leute auf geht's ich bin so gespannt
er ist schon ziemlich wenn er zu uns
geschmeckt weil an sich mag ich fotos
nur die einzig gute natürlich gefällt er
[Musik]
so ok david garrett classic chili cheese
christi was geht
ich hätte gern einmal die kraft einmal
gutklassigen spiel christi und eine
große kohle gesprochen hatte ich kenne
den nicht dass ihr denkt ich sage auch
ich sowas geht also den die auf diesem
plakat aus wenn diese schmecken diese
aussehen
dann wird vielleicht lecker
2000 jahre später
wenn ihr damals schmecken die sich auf
der genau wie viele folgen
und
barrichello 3
so leute herzlich willkommen zurück ich
muss sagen ich hab jetzt verdammt nach
deswegen wieder heftige ernährung ab
staffel deswegen würde ich sagen wir
fangen uns voran theoretisch natürlich
auch einfach alle drei probieren können
ich weiß nicht warum ich jetzt nur zwei
bestellt habe aber der dritte 6 wir
haben jetzt einmal hier wir haben jetzt
einmal den classic den mache ich jetzt
mal auf zum anbeißen lecker aus da will
man am liebsten drüber schlafen und dann
haben wir noch den christie war das
glaube ich schaut euch den waren somit
rest ziegelmeier ich mega ich würde aber
sagen ich fange mit dem classic jahren
als rektor das ist ein bisschen
unappetitlich dass es hier raus gelaufen
ist aber wir probieren jetzt mach ich
max
[Musik]
also wenn ich um ehrlich zu sein
allgemein schmeckt nur ich finde es ein
bisschen zu viel größer und so traurig
weiß nie erlebt hat er wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
also schmeckt auf jeden fall nachmittag
aber was die fleißig angeht habe ich auf
jeden fall schon bessere tage gästen ein
favorit war ja sowieso ihr dieser
christi oder wieder ist also vom
aussehen her sieht ja auf jeden fall
kommt aus wir probieren jetzt mal
[Musik]
das ist auf jeden fall richtig gut
richtig gutes richtig guter richtig
gutes motto heißt es das hat der hat
doch schmeckt auf jeden fall gut
[Musik]
also kurze zusammenfassung ich finde an
sich einen hotdog passt jetzt vielleicht
nicht so unbedingt zu burger klingen
aber wann kann ich denn sagen weil das
kispi hot hat echt mega gut geschmeckt
also wenn er malt arbeit und auch mal
hott abholen wollte probiert man das
christi das andere fand ich ein bisschen
zufolge klatschte ansonsten nicht sagen
ich hoffe ja spaß im anfangs noch nach
oben dabei ist gefallen hat trägt auf
jeden fall snapple von instagram ab und
ich fliege morgen früh nach salzburg wir
sehen uns am samstag auf der durchreise
kommt vorbei und ich wünsche euch noch
ein schönes wochenende hart rein